um all right so uh compilation coming
next
month uh you got the project out right
now uh singles going it crazy right
now um I me you've had success at Radio
before Texas is gold or platinum
now uh I think it's damn near
Platinum Platinum mhm um but like I feel
like this record I see the way it's
moving up on the radio chart too I think
it's already go we just waiting on to
the what is it the raia certification go
there you go yeah yeah well congrats man
and then you uh and uh you guys got the
600 compilation coming yes sir that's
going to go
crazy I'mma play you one song like
whenever it's all over just so you it's
called the Sixers welcome to the meet
the Sixers are you guys gonna have some
Sixers looking
merch of course by the way I spent good
money on your Texas Ranger shirt not the
not the best quality the print
sucked the tea was nice you care they
fired the print was whatever but the tea
was really nice thick t-shirt good
t-shirt it was a bad DTG job I was like
you know what I [__] with this shirt
though I'm going to get one good wear
out of it cuz once it's washed it's a
rap and I was right damn
cuz we
got don't worry about we just had a
meeting with who is that that we just
had a meeting with Brandon network
network that's what I'm going to be
doing my merch with now uh how excited
like I you're I mean you obviously [__]
with the Rangers were you excited you
guys beat my Diamondbacks in the World
Series I was in Texas at the time you
know as soon as they won you know so
what song you think played Texas yeah
but I'm just saying like were you a
baseball fan like that I I didn't know I
I threw the first pitch that was my
first time ever going to a baseball game
peeee how was how was it was it good
like a pitch did you get it over the
plate strike it was a strike what I did
good
right bro he always hating it was you
could do better it was straight it was
30 m per hour that's not fast but it was
a curve be like it but it was a strike
cuz you you remember when remember when
50 sent through that [__] and that [__]
went like oh yeah n no see it went right
to the hand right yeah I got a were you
at did you did you like do Sports I had
my shirt on but oh you were outside I
was I was the first person yeah on that
baseball field with that shirt off
history I believe
you I ain't know I don't know nobody
else that I don't know I don't watch
baseball like that I but I threw the
first pitch with I had the Jersey on but
it was not butting they tried to make me
button it
well listen man I'm very uh excited for
you guys proud of you keep killing it uh
your Texans are still alive shout out to
CJ stad have you dm' him like Hey CJ
thank you bro I don't want to [__] up
nothing don't [__] it up so I'm just
going to let everything play out and
then when they do cuz they just wanted
me to come to the gameer and perform at
the little halftime [__] but I was I had
a show so I could but I'm just trying to
stay the [__] up cuz everything sports
related that I've done anything for yeah
they lost right so I'm just trying to
stay the [__] away have you done
something for the Mavs
yet uh
no that's probably why they they right
now how manyan all
right the Cowboys they I'm like they
theme song they paid me to remix it and
some other [__] yeah uh the Rangers what
about the Stars they they like they play
it in the arena but it's like we ain't
got no do they still do like I just
watched this movie called The ironclaw
about the Von Erics which I've never
been to a a wrestling show is what I was
going to ask Oh I thought you was to say
I was going to say wrestling because in
Texas like I didn't realize in Dallas
it's like that's where the Von Eric's
there's a big movie out Zack Fone
starting in it it's about this wrestling
family from Texas that was like the
worst luck ever but they're all from
Dallas there was a place called uh the
sportatorium in Dallas back in the day
where they used to have these
independent wrestling shows where Stone
Cold came up came up
man y' ain't watching wrestling you
still watch wrestling notore I watch
wrestling I a watch wrestling since I
was in like Middle School yeah not
tripping that shit's fire I'm going to
Royal Rumble next week I I would go to a
wrestl man though I would because it
would piss me off I will go to the nah
bro cuz if you went they'll [__] put
you in the ring and you'll be able to
like do a move they you'll lay somebody
out but I'm but I would still be mad cuz
now I got to fake the
move it don't matter it's my sound
effect is not the best
you see you see Snoop Dog wrestling yeah
yeah you got to get on that that was
back then this sh was last year at
WrestleMania he wrestled I'm talking
about long time ago when he was on there
he's wrestled like 30 times Snoop Dogg
is the side quest King yeah he got a lot
of [__] going you'll be like what the
[__] what you see how he just did us
with the no smoking [__] yeah and the
all time he was talking about a [__]
Gill and the guy I guess it didn't work
for the
so the CEO of that company just got
fired because that marketing idea
probably cost them a bunch of money to
pay s didn't result in many stoves sold
C all right so next time I'm going to
come to Texas we're going to go murder
some pigs let's do it and we're going to
go we're going to go eat um Chicken
Express yeah okay we're going to go get
Ranch wings from Walmart Ranch wings
from Walmart and we're going to get them
for free and I'm going to show you
H okay so we're going to go we're going
to go steal um which I'm I'm comfortable
with we could Vlog it I mean and then
just drop it after like five years you
know uh and then uh I guess we'll go to
a Texans game oh can't do that can't do
it that's too far uh Cowboys game I
can't do that season's over huh take you
Rudy rud chicken chicken okay you like
chicken
yeah don't like this I like Raising
Canes man take n This Hood n Hood
chicken right here okay where they got
the little Ash on the elbow yeah and
it's like chickens have Ash on their
elbows the cook for sure got Ash on his
elbow for sure yeah for sure well look
man I'll see y'all out there soon um
make sure you guys go support go stream
new music on the way and uh any videos
coming yeah we got a lot of videos
coming too many to even talk about would
you and yo ever do a project together
yeah I do a project with them feel like
you guys are [__] when you guys are I
just been so I've been busy we've been
talked about it this guy's busy man he
can barely even walk through a Walmart
anymore either because he's banned or
he's really famous and gets
recognized one of the two it's the ble C
podcast appreciate y'all man sir fire